you want some
more no you are get out of here if this
is about the screaming some wack job
stuck his head in my window and kept
calling me a failure but I took care of
him Marvin flute I should have known
you'd be Friday Drunk On A Tuesday
Lieutenant Kang you're like my College
alumni donation Department you can
somehow find me anywhere we got a case
only you can solve and an opening on the
cornhole team for this weekend's
cornment did you forget you took my
badge Lieutenant no excuse me I got to
get back to the only things I'm good at
anymore drinking myself to death and
painstakingly crafting mid-century
modern dollhouse furniture oh little
tiny chair in your little perfect world
oh what I'd give to spin around on you
and go but I'm too big I would crush you
and that would crush me well then I
guess you don't want this back badgy hi
Mr girl have you seen Coffey what about
crime tapy not until you crack this
week's bizarre unsolvable case dare I go
back to grimburg the town I left behind
like a perfectly timed elevator fart a
place permanently cursed a century ago
by a virgin sacrifice gone sideways a
city so full of Vice they named it twice
then realized that sounded dumb so they
went back to just the one
word grim wait oh is
it wow big
bite
[Music]
grimburg